[Musique]
je vais toujours au contact à porter
d'engueulades je le dis et j'y tiens
les gens expriment leur colère parfois
leur désarroi je suis toujours là
parfois j'ai la réponse d'autres fois je
ne l'est pas j'essaie de la bâtir
parfois je me trompe d'autres fois j'y
arrive ça c'est la colère légitime et on
sera toujours là pour y répondre la
bêtise de la violence non l'auteur de la
gifle d'amiante et pourrait faire
l'objet d'une comparution immédiate dès
demain à la mi journée
il aurait été en état d'ébriété au
moment des faits c'est un geste grave
contre une personne
oui pour tous quelle personne quand elle
fait l'objet de violences est un jeune
homme est grave c'est un geste grave
contre la fonction de président de la
république et c'est un geste grave
contre la nation française dans son
ensemble domicile du deuxième interpellé
le livre d'adolphe hitler mein kampf a
été saisi ainsi que plusieurs armes et
on ignore s'il s'agit de vrais ou de
répliques ne faut pas donner le
sentiment que ce qui a été fait par cet
homme est représentatif de la société de
la population française y compris d'une
forme de colère de la part d'une partie
des français
les épisodes de la crise sanitaire le
confinement etc explique un certain
nombre de réalités mais la violence ou
le savez bien dans une société
démocratique the lady la violence la
haine l'exclusion ne seront jamais une
solution
je pense que la meilleure réponse à cela
c'est de ne pas changer de ne pas
s'arrêter de ne pas dramatiser la
situation mais sans négliger la force et
la violence symbolique du geste
eric zemmour il dit il s'est lui-même
désacraliser en parlant du président de
la république il a ce qu'il mérite
bon c'est horrible à dire et je condamne
mais il a ce qu'il a provoqué ont écouté
je suis pas sûr d'avoir très envie de
commenter les propos d'eric zemmour qui
fait partie de ceux qui effectivement
sont en permanence dans l'outrance et la
caricature
j'ai été extrêmement choqué par ces
images et par leur violence parce que
c'est une atteinte évidemment à la
figure d'autorité suprême au président
de la république et donc à la république
elle-même
bien sûr il faut condamner cet acte mais
il renvoie à une réalité à une réalité
que nous vivons au quotidien qui est que
tout
les figures d'autorité aujourd'hui sont
menacés monté en violences qui devient
un phénomène social et finalement cette
gifle d'un point de vue physique est
bien moins grave que ce que l'on peut
hélas rencontrés au quotidien dans
beaucoup de situations je crois qu'il ya
120 rixe au couteau par jour en france
aujourd'hui
voilà la situation du pays un chiffre
terrible hand années 2020 1300 élus
locaux ont été agressés ils ont été
agressés physiquement je ne compte pas
les agressions verbales et moi je veux
saluer l'union républicaine qui a été
exprimée hier par je crois l'ensemble
des formations politiques que ce soit
dans l'hémicycle à l'assemblée nationale
ou en dehors pour dénoncer cet acte
président a rappelé également qu'il faut
regarder cet acte pour ce qu'il est
c'est à dire un fait isolé d'un individu
violent et la franche personne n'a
l'intention de tuer le chef de l'état et
puis si jamais il ya des fous ici ou là
bon les officiers de sécurité ils savent
régler ça je me déplaçais naroui
hélicoptère et ouvrages pour surtout
cherché
sachez qu'une enquête a été ouverte pour
provocation au north contre le youtuber
papa sitôt enquête qui fait suite à une
plainte déposée par jean luc mélenchon
papa si tôt avait publié lundi une vidéo
mettant en scène le meurtre fictive d'un
membre de la france en soumises 18,8
millions de dollars c'est le prix de la
pièce de monnaie
vendu hier aux enchères par la maison
sotheby's un exemplaire qui fait partie
des dernières séries de pièces d'or dit
double eagle parce qu'elle est frappée
par la monnaie des etats-unis à 133 elle
devient donc la pièce la plus chère du
monde
alors les discothèques rendez vous le 21
juin avec moi